I can't change this situation I I am
surrendering to prison ET confirms Jen
Shaw has begun her six and a half year
sentence
after reporting to federal prison camp
in Bryan Texas I have already made some
bad decisions in her final interview
before the Big House Jen reveals the two
items she's bringing with her you know
you mentioned I'm getting ready to
surrender in a few hours I'm going in
with two things the Quran and my
released fan The Real Housewives of Salt
Lake City Star opens up to author Justin
paperny a convicted felon who get this
now prepares people to go to prison this
release plan is not only my road map but
it's what is going to hold me
accountable for you know
for everything that I I am I'm telling
you know that I told the judge in
sentencing
how you doing how are you doing I will
make sure that I make these victims
whole this release plan is going to help
me be successful so that I can I can do
that Jen's lawyer tells ET in a
statement quote with the unwavering love
and support of her family and friends
Jen is prepared to face these challenges
head on and emerge from this experience
a better person meanwhile Jen's Salt
Lake TV fam is moving on a source tells
E.T season 4 filming kicks off next week
if the worst thing happens and I'm so
guilty like
can you please check on my family do you
think the show can survive without her I
think Housewives can survive without any
of us it's its own sight guys I think if
you can get women to put their lives on
camera from Salt Lake City you'll always
have a franchise there Jen's new reality
a 37-acre minimum security prison where
there's 559 inmates she can buy mascara
and bronzer from the commissary and Jen
won't be the only star there for long
disgraced theranos founder Elizabeth
Holmes reports to that same prison in
April her sentence 11 years I feel
devastated as Jen starts a new chapter
Behind Bars her lawyer is already
looking to the Future tweeting let's
talk 2029. we've already made some bad
decisions I have already
um
hurt people
now I really I I'm committed to
making a change and and
making this as positive as I possibly
can
thank you
[Music]